il m'a été demandé le retour du fond
bleu dont je vous ai mis un peu de fond
bloc lumière bleue comment vous allez ça
se passe bien pour vous j'espère vous
allez bien aujourd'hui on va parler de
wang place vous en douterez vous le
voyez dans le titre sinon vous seriez
peut-être pas là on va paraître ses
smartphones la sspt patronat joue les ai
déjà présenté je vous ai fait une
première vidéo de présentation des
produits et aujourd'hui eh bien on va
regarder quels sont les points qui vous
permettront tout cas d'aller l'acheter
et les points qui feront qu'il faut fuir
il faut surtout pas l'acheter j'ai donc
aujourd'hui 9 points positifs et 5
points négatifs 9 points positifs pour
lesquels il faut aller acheter ses
produits ou une +9 points de plus neuf
pros et 5 points négatifs qui feront qu
il va falloir que vous passiez votre
chemin alors à vous de vous faire votre
idée bien évidemment est ce que ces
smartphones sont faits pour vous pas
vous êtes la meilleure personne pour le
savoir la mieux placée pour le savoir
mais en tout cas je vais vous dire ce
qu'il en est gelée mon retour plus tôt
que vous faire un test un petit peu
standard un peu classique quand vous en
trouvez beaucoup et bien j'ai préféré le
prendre de cette manière là et regardez
au final est-ce que c'est one + 9 eoin
de plus neuf pros sont intéressants wii
ou pas du tout
[Musique]
on va tout c'est de commencer dans le
positif on va commencer par le premier
pôle premier point qui pour moi
important qui est un des gros points
forts de ce smartphone de ses
smartphones que ce soit et quoi de plus
naturel plus neuf pros eh bien c'est la
recharge la recharge rapide de
regardez-moi ça là vous avez un bloc de
charge qui juste hyper hyper hyper hyper
master qu'ont les gens de 65 watts
on est sur du 10 volts et 6.5 en perd ça
c'est en rapport avec la vidéo je vous
ai fait de joe pour vous parler des
blocs de chasse locale et un petit coup
d'oeil si vous n'avez pas encore vu ce
qui fait qu ici vous allez recharger
votre smartphone de 0 à 100 % en moins
d'une demi heure en moins d'une demi
heure
c'est de la charge basse tension vous
avez en fait deux batteries de 2250
meilleure paire eur
dans chaque smartphone pour un total de
4500 millions terreur et ça c'est super
cool c'est vraiment un des très gros
point positif que vous allez retrouver
ici chez eux ou en place donc ça c'est
que la recharge filaire mais vous avez
en plus de la charge sans fil 50 watts
qui va d'ailleurs plus vite que beaucoup
de smartphones qui seront un peu plus
cher vous leurs charges et de 0 à 100 %
en moins de 45 minutes en charge sans
fil autant vous dire que ça c'est super
super super intéressant donc ici on se
posera plus la question de se dire je
vais être en rade de smartphones j'ai un
problème à main c'est oublié de le
charger là j'ai oublié de le charger
avant de faire le feu tournage
qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai pris tous
les deux je les ai branché là dedans et
je suis parti pour vous faire cette
vidéo sans aucun problème en charge est
très très très rapidement donc ça pour
moi c'est un gros point positif
vous vous levez le matin il est pas
charger qu'est ce que vous faites vous
le prenez vous branchez vous vous l'avez
vous ressenti de la douche vous êtes
prêt il est chargé vous pouvez attaquer
votre journée vous tenez une journée
comme ça avec cette charge rapide sans
problème ça pour moi c'est un des très
très gros point fort à noter ici le
bémol parce que quand même un petit
bémol ça c'est le one + 9 s'éloigne plus
neuf pros sur le wan +9
vous n'avez pas de charge son fils 50
watts vous avez uniquement mets des
guillemets quand j'ai uniquement vous
avez uniquement ici de la charge sans
fil 65 watts qui est déjà quand même
relativement énorme
le deuxième point qui vous incitera à
venir et hse smartphone c'est la
performance la performance sina dragon
888 8 ou 12 igad rams et de la lpddr2 5
ces monstres de puissance
vous avez soit 128 soit 256 go de
stockage onu fs3 présent ça marche bien
ça écrit vite salive itsa performe ça va
super bien
avait aujourd'hui ce qui serait mieux
donc si vous voulez un smartphone pour
le gaming
oui faire tourner des forces night à
fond la caisse vous voulez quelque chose
d' extrêmement performant qui ira très
vite qui répondra parfaitement à toutes
vos sollicitations
là vous avez vraiment ce qu'il faut et
c'est pour moi un des très gros point
fort de smartphones et ça lui apporte en
plus beaucoup de polyvalence dont
beaucoup d' usage autre très grand point
positif ici chez elle pleure et bien
c'est l'expérience logiciel vous avez
oxygène os aux c'est une des meilleures
expériences on peut retrouver sur
android a beaucoup il y en a qui
s'améliore mais celle là elle est
vraiment intéressante vous êtes sur un
android
11 ici tout est clair et très très très
lisible vous avez accès à vos différents
réglages vous différents paramètres très
facilement
l'expérience elle est vraiment vraiment
top optimiser en plus pour le gaming
vous pouvez créer votre compte moi je
n'ai pas fait ne pouvait créer un compte
et venir vous identifier ici vous pouvez
aller loin bien évidemment au niveau des
paramètres de votre écran vous avez des
fonctions avancées sur le taux de
rafraîchissement et pas mal de
possibilités
je donne un quatrième point positif
avant de passer sur un point négatif
parce que s'il n'y a pas que des points
positifs
un point positif que j'aime beaucoup et
si ce sont les finitions les finitions
sont superbes
vous avez un smartphone qui est beau que
ce soit au niveau du module photo au
niveau du dos au niveau des boutons au
niveau de ce petit slide on vous
retrouve est toujours ici chez one plus
pour venir à passer sur le mode
silencieux le mode vibreur ou pour
activer le volume vous avez de très très
très belle finition sur le module photo
si c'est vachement bien laurie si vous
prenez forcément les traces de doigts ça
oui et ça vient justement introduire mon
partenaire c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo
qui a réalisé en partenariat avec rideau
chine parce que oui avoir un beau
smartphone c'est bien mais il faut venir
le protéger je voulais des jouets dit
plein de fois ça évitera déjà que vous
ayez des traces de doigts donc serait
c'est quand même un gros point positif
et bien vous et du corning gorilla glass
un qu'à l'arrière également à la vente
est bien moins comme ça ça viendra
renforcer et ça c'est super alors pour
mieux protéger chirino chine y en a pour
tout le monde et pour tous les goûts
vous avez coque sympa comme ça tout
sobre qui va venir sans vote one + 9 pro
ou alors carrément du quart-arrière va
lui mettre du carbone à donner un côté
un peu sportif moderne regarder ça comme
c'est mignon ça marche très très bien
c'est très sympa sur le one + 9 onces
multicoques tout noir comme ça tout
sympa bien évidemment vous retrouvé vos
boutons
c'est fonctionnel ça marche bien ces
pratiques qui sont malins ils ont pensé
à tout et en plus avec des coques dans
plein d'univers différents alors vous le
savez on a les chicago bulls si vous
aimez sport y en a pleins il yad'autres
de la nba d'aller voir sur leur site
je vous ai mis le lien dans la
description et en plus de ça vous avez 5
% de remise grâce aux codes qui en bas
dans la description c'est le code greu
21 ce serait dommage de ne pas profiter
du forfait du fairy tail vous avez du
hunter vous aurez pour tout le monde et
même des coques a promis pour la nasa
oui messieurs dames c'est pas mal
assassination classroom et en plus de ça
vous avez des coques psg qui vont
arriver et dé coke one piece donc ça
c'est sympa c'est très bon ce que je
vous invite donc à terme fournir protégé
ici votre smartphone de one plus c'est
devenir cliquez sur le lien en bas dans
la description profiter des soldes % de
remise également penser à bien protéger
la face avant sur smartphones y en a
tous les côtés gars des accessoires ya
des impacts screen protector ça c'est
plutôt bien et c'est une très bonne
nouvelle on va passer maintenant sur les
points négatifs
le premier point négatif qui ferait que
vous devez passer votre chemin
c'est la partie audio pour moi la partie
audio avec le haut parleur un jeu pas
vraiment au niveau du haut parleur
on n'est pas vraiment à la hauteur il
n'y a pas que wang plus qui est pas très
bon là dessus il y en a quelques-uns et
c'est toujours un peu dommage je vous
fait écouter je pousse le son à fond là
vous avez votre haut parleur un essai
tout sur le côté alors principal vous
j'aime autant l'un est situé jusqu'ici
dans le haut parleur qu'on va utiliser
pour me repasser nous appels
téléphoniques et en fait ce qui est
problématique et ce qui est dommage
c'est que vous avez un vrai déséquilibre
ici là vous avez votre haut parleurs
principal qui lui par contre marche pas
mal nous avons inspecté vraiment bien du
son qui est grave
un bon volume ça marche bien et le
deuxième est situé ici en façade ce qui
fait que je voulais déjà les pleins de
fois ici on part par là ici on part sur
le devant est ici le son va être
beaucoup plus médium est beaucoup moins
fort dont vous avez un vrai déséquilibre
lorsque vous écoutez de la musique avec
d'un côté un son qui sera plus ample et
de meilleure qualité sur la droite est
beaucoup plus faible et plus étriqué sur
la gauche c'est pas terrible terrible
est sûre ça dommage
dans une expérience d'un smartphone a
presque 1000 euros on va maintenant
passer un bon positif un des gros points
positifs à des très gros point positif
de ce de ses smartphones mais surtout du
modèle professionnel c'est son écran
vous avez une superbe dalle mais
tellement bien maîtrisé
j'aime ici c'est qu'effectivement vous
avez un écran incurvé déjà ça c'est
vachement sympa ça apporte beaucoup plus
en immersion je le préfère à l'écran
plat qu'on va voir sur le wan +9
d'autant plus que si vous êtes sur un
écran de 6,7 pouces vous êtes sûr de
l'amoled ltp en quad hd + 120 hertz
adaptatif
vous avez un écran hd r10 plus 10 bits
super lumineux très très beau boulot sur
le modèle pro sur l'autre c'est bien on
n'ira pas aussi loin on n'aura pas un
taux de rafraîchissement 100 hertz
adaptatif on sera pas sur du ltp où on
est un peu en dessous mais pour moi le
gros coup de coeur au niveau de l'écran
il est clairement ici sur le wan +9 pro
a et on va continuer maintenant avec les
autres points positifs avec la photo sur
la photo il ya un très beau boulot de
fait il ya des choses qui sont vraiment
super d'autres qui sont un peu moins
bien que vous montrez j'ai tout de suite
votre je vous le dis tout de suite entre
le one + 9 et one + 9 pro on a une
différence au niveau du capteur
principal
vous n'avez pas le même capteur saunier
de l'un à l'autre par contre l'ultra
grand angle à sera exactement le même
là on est sur les photos prises avec le
one + 9 je vous montre juste après
maintes +9 trop regarder on est sur une
photo là que je trouve super sympa ce
que vous en bar tendance à faire ses
smartphones c'est à compenser d'un point
de vue logiciel pour ajouter plus de
piquet donc on se retrouve avec des
photos avec beaucoup de piquer avec du
détail des fois un peu trop et à
outrance et ça on en reparle dans
quelques instants
regardez votre capteur principal c'est
sympa on a une belle gestion de la
lumière
l'ultra grand donc forcément une
différence de colorimétrie on s'en
doutera ça c'est normal on n'est pas sûr
d'être capteurs là aussi c'est très
sympa garder je vous fait voyager je
vous emmène là dans le bassin d'arcachon
c'est sympa comme tout gardella grand
angle ultra grand angle on voit la
différence une colorimétrie au niveau du
sable là on est plus pâle là on est un
peu plus sur deûle orange et jaune
orangé la même chose là très bien très
bonne gestion de la plage dynamique ça
marche bien grand angle ultra grand
angle parfait on passant le modèle
professionnel regarda ici comme ça
marche très très bien la gestion de la
plage dynamique
on a bien le soleil dit simon voit quand
même la partie du clocher je pense que
c'est le clocher on voit bien tous les
nuages ou tout on a bien toutes les
pierres ici en façade on voit même ici
les détails au niveau de l'arbre on à la
façade arrière rien est cramé derrière
on voit bien aussi toutes les zones qui
sont au soleil et quand on passe un
ultra grand angle c'est la même chose ça
marche bien on perd un poil en précision
mais ça marche même très très bien
regardez là comme c'est chouette
la paf ça marche bien regardez-moi ça
regardez moi ça est-ce que c'est pas
beau l'auvergne
salle et ça c'est votre grand angle et
paf l'ultra grand temps que ça souffle
ses magnifiques moi j'adore regarder ça
comme c'est mignon grand angle la neige
on voit bien tout on passe sur l'ultra
grand temps que c'est la même chose
c'est préserver ça marche bien ce qui
nous emmène au septième point c'est la
faute aux nuits sur le grand angle
regardez ça regardez ça j'adore alors on
voit que la lgo et qu'on pense à mort
ici c'est qu'on pense et on le voit bien
gardé mais le la lune qui vient se
réfléchir ici c'est magnifique je vois
bien la lutte j'ai mon ciel j'ai tout on
voit que le logiciel est là ces a pas
goûté hypra naturel on reprend que ces
retouches et en fait alors que c'est pas
le tour touché c'est vraiment sortie de
smartphones moi j'adore j'ai un super
super jolie regarder ça regardez ça le
ciel on voit bien les étoiles je n'ai
pas posé sur un trépied alors je me suis
calé sur le coin d'une fenêtre mais ça
marche vraiment super bien et voilà le
boulot là dessus est vraiment bien fait
ce qui nous emmène au deuxième point
négatif la raison pour laquelle il
faudrait oublier ce smartphone est bien
c'est la photo sur lui très grand-angle
regarder franchement c'est pas
qualitatif du tout c'est pas beau c'est
imprécis on a du mal à avoir une image
avec un beau rendu alors là j'ai un poil
moins bouger sur celle là mais moi je
suis pas fan suis vraiment pas fan gradé
de la même manière ici mais la scapa
stabilisation dans forcément avec moi ça
ne pardonne pas pareil outre à grand
angle pas stabilisation ça ne pardonne
pas c'est pas uniquement le fait du one
+ 9 ou moins de plus neuf pros beaucoup
de smartphones vous propose sa
aujourd'hui sur la food nuit avec un
ultra grand-angle c'est pas
extraordinaire mais voilà il est plus
simple qu'on va retrouver sur beaucoup
de smartphones donc là c'est vraiment
compliqué de lui en tenir rigueur
ce qui nous amène au troisième point
négatif c'est la compensation logiciel
au niveau des photos ici vous avez trop
de piqué je trouve qu'il ya trop de
piquer l'or parfois ça marche
lorsqu'il vient compenser les scènes qui
nécessiteront d'avoir un peu plus de
piquer mais parfois c'est un peu trop
ici on va retrouver beaucoup trop de
détails et c'est pas d'un god 1 go on le
voit au niveau du sable au niveau de
différents endroits relevons également
au niveau des vagues
je trouve ça dommage et une compensation
logiciels et ça en fait un petit peu
trop alors ça bien typés les images
d'une certaine manière est de notre côté
voilà ça ça ça en fait un peu trop ce
qui nous emmène au huitième point
positif de ce smartphone est bien c'est
la lentille freeform sur le capteur
ultra grand-angle hors jeu pas si vous
vous souvenez on en a parlé ya pas
longtemps avec le au pot funding iii pro
parce que oui si il ya une partie de la
r&d qui est partagé entre au pot et
wyplosz font partie du même groupe dont
je passe un petit peu l'histoire c'est
anti free form
elle va venir optiquement et vite
qui est trop de déformation éviter de
base d'un des formations au niveau des
pneus sont ultra grand angle et regarder
ça marche quand même pas mal alors on a
quand même une certaine déformation à
celle optique c'est un ultra grand temps
que c'est normal on est dans un
smartphone mais ça fonctionne je suis un
petit extra sur cette partie photo
notamment sur le wan +9 projet pas
incorporé dans mes plus dans mémoires
mais c'est vraiment histoire de venir
compléter comme ça vous verrez tout
lorsque vous êtes sur le téléobjectif
l'acteur principal ultra-grand-angle
j'aime rapprocher ce que dit de me
rapprocher un peu mais des liens
rapprochés un poteau tout de suite on le
voit on perd en détail on récupère du
bruit et il faut pas aller trop trop
loin sans quoi tout de suite c'est
vraiment pas beau pas beau il ya un
autre point qui est assez sympa sur ses
smartphones la sec avec votre capteur
ultra grand-angle vous pouvez faire de
la macro c'est un des rares smartphones
qui fait bizarre de la macro donc je
tenais vraiment à le dire souligné parce
que en règle générale la macro sans
smartphone se fait avec un capteur dédié
de 2 août 5 mégapixels et le rendu est
pas terrible comme là on est sur un 50
méga pixels sur un ultra grand-angle on
arrive à des choses qui sont vraiment
pas mal et bien détaillé regardez ici
dans des choses qui sont vraiment très
sympa même sort de la glace on arrive à
récupérer des choses plutôt pas mal
donc là dessus il ya aussi un très beau
boulot a été fait de la part de one love
point de détail en passant aussi
rapidement les photos prises avec la
caméra delphi sont pas mal regardé
j'aime bien on a bien du détail ça me
fait un petit flou léger au niveau de
l'arrière-plan une des grosses
différences que vous avez entre ces deux
smartphones et sur le one + 9 vous
n'avez pas de télé objectifs et là vous
le voyez vraiment qu'un capteur
principal non pas sur lui très
grand-angle on vient se rapprocher un
petit peu on peut on peut vraiment très
légèrement mais ça commence déjà à venir
meilleurs lycées mais l'algorithme de
chercher à contention et là tout de
suite sur le sable ça ne pardonne pas à
regarder là je vois là je sais pas si
vous comprenez ce qui se passe autre
point négatif sur ses smartphones c'est
qu'ici et bien vous n'avez absolument
aucune prise jack non il y en a pas
nulle part tous les côtés donc si vous
voulez écouter de la musique avec un
casque il faudra vous contenter
contenter entre guillemets du bluetooth
5.2 9e gros point positif pour ses
smartphones
et bien c'est tout le reste vous avez
une certification il pèse 68 kg et est
même plutôt rare chez points de plus et
qui arrive comme ça c'est super
intéressant vous êtes du nfc grand
classique vous avez bien évidemment du
wifi 6 vous avez plein de connaître
grâce au bluetooth 5.2 à ptx à ptx hdl
d'acs a assez vous avez de quoi faire
sont des smartphones qui sont très
complet cinquième point négatif sur ses
smartphones eh ben c'est pas j'ai pas
trouvé j'ai pas trouvé de cinquième
point négatif alors je vous en ai mis un
cinquième de plus parce que je trouvais
qu'il fallait un peu équilibré
l'histoire si je vous mettais que les
taux de positif est pas négatif
ça crée un peu mais voyez je n'ai pas
nécessairement je n'ai pas de cinquième
point négatif après tout un chacun y
verra des points positifs ou des points
négatifs mais moi je les aime bien je
les aime bien ces smartphones et je
trouve vraiment mais vraiment que one +
a bien bossé sa copie sur ces deux
produits là ils sont beaux ils sont
élégants ils marchent bien ils sont
performants l'autonomie ça aurait pu
être en cinquième mort sixième point
négatif parce que ça va vraiment
dépendre de vous et de vos usages si
vous en avez un usage un peu intensif
vous ne tiendrez pas une journée ou une
journée tout au plus si vous êtes un peu
plus cool vous pourrez approcher de la
journée et demie les deux jours ça fait
un petit peu complexe là dessus c'est
pas le smartphone qui sera le plus
endurant mais dans l'est tellement
rassuré que ce blog de charge 65 watts
qu'on se pose pas la question
l'autonomie quelque part on sait que
même si l'autonomie c'est peut-être pas
la meilleure ici dépasse et qui tiendra
le plus longtemps
on s'en fiche parce qu'on le prend en
branche voulaient ces dix minutes un
quart d'heure vous êtes parti pour la
journée vous êtes tranquille et ça c'est
vachement bien on a donc deux
smartphones très complet bien évidemment
je préférais le modèle pro en s'en
doutera pas ce qu'il en fera beaucoup
plus mais il ya une grosse différence de
prix le guen +9 va être disponible à 719
euros
d'ailleurs je mets le lien en bas dans
la description tandis que le modèle
professionnel à 919 euros il ya un écart
qui est assez conséquent qui va se faire
dans la partie photo au niveau du
capteur principal qui va se faire au
niveau de l'écran donc si vous le pouvez
sous j'en avais les moyens s'il vous
convient le one + 9 pro est vraiment
bien
le one + 9 est aussi très bien et moi ce
que je vois et ce qui m'intéresse c'est
super intéressant ici si vous voulez
c'est que wyplosz bien un petit peu
rattrapé son retard en termes de photos
il n'était pas toujours très très très
bien placé moi je trouvais assez
efficace globalement mais c'est vrai que
par rapport à une concurrence qui est
extrêmement puissante et bien wyplosz
avait besoin d'aller un poil plus loin
quand même dans cette partie là donc là
justement ils vont plus loin
c'est intéressant ça marche bien mais en
tout cas j'aime beaucoup et je dis
félicitations à mme perez a vous de me
dire vous maintenant ce que vous en
pensez quels sont vos points positifs
par rapport à ce matin quels sont vos
points négatifs
mark et moi tout ça bien évidemment on
va aux commentaires quand on se retrouve
très vite nous envoie du gros bisous
prenez soin de vous et puis surtout
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner d'activer
la cloche pour la division métaux ciao
ciao